la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
c'est savoir qu'est-ce que vous
choisiriez vous entre un pc et entre une
tablette alors regardez je vous montre
un plat on s'abîme ça et on va regarder
on a deux machines ici on a cette
machine là et on a celle là qu'est ce
que vous choisiriez vous entre un pc et
une tablette c'est la question qu'on va
venir se poser sauf que en réalité ici
c'est pas un pc et une tablette bien que
ça ressemble à une tablette c'est un pc
et un pc un pc et un pc ça ça
m'intéresse pourquoi parce qu'on va
venir se parler d' usage on va essayer
de comprendre comment ça fonctionne on
veut nous mettre en face d'eux produite
chez huawei à savoir le my book 16 que
vous avez là c'est à dire quand même
gros mais debout cash ouah c'est le plus
gros mais debout qui existe aujourd'hui
et puis le met debout que eux qui est
également un pc mais qu' un pc avec le
look and feel d'une tablette c'est à
dire un qui bordent détachable
c'est-à-dire un style et qu'on va avoir
la qui veut être et beauté sur le dessus
et puis j'en appelle à l'unité centrale
écran tout en haut puisque ce n'est pas
une tablette c'est un pc donc
aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat déco et parce que
huawei venu voir mika monsieur heureux
on aimerait bien te montrer deux
produits on aimerait bien que tu nous
dis ce que tu en penses que tu vois les
usages à quoi servent ces deux produits
donc on va venir aujourd'hui se mettre
en face à face et bien le macbook 16 le
côté très grand et l'autre côté plus de
modularité avec le macbook on y va matin
parce que vous en pensez mais pour moi
c'est sûr quand on regarde ça comme ça
on se dit j'ai un pc j'ai une tablette
ah oui bien évidemment c'est hop il est
bien dit montesquieu est ce que vous
l'assuré ça ressemble à une tablette sel
ça semble être un poil plus épais
peut-être quoique vraiment pas grand
chose mais ça ressemble vraiment une
tablette et pour autant ça c'est pas une
tablette c'est toujours surprenant
d'avoir ça comme ça c'est un vrai pc un
vrai pc sous windows avec tout ce que
vous allez pouvoir à venir retrouvez ici
alors l'idée du met debout que parce que
c'est son nom le man booker et bien
c'est la modularité c'est le fait de se
dire ok on n'a pas toujours besoin d'un
pc d'un grand pc comme celui-là comme le
macbook 16 le macbook 16 il est hyper
canon sept plus gros mais debout qui
existent aujourd'hui vous avez quand
même un écran qui est extrêmement rare
garder alors attendez je vais vous le
dire parce que j'ai les chiffres quelque
part par là ils sont notées ici pour
vous le dire exactement là c'est un
écran de 16 pouces qui est quand même un
peu mastoc et attendez on va digérer ça
allait pas tactile c'est vrai hop là on
a un
écran de 16 pouces cdu 2,5 carte c'est à
dire 2520 par
1660 c'est un ratio 3 2 me alors la
différence du 3/2 et du 16/9 c'est à
dire qu'en fait le 16/9 ça à venir
s'arrêter pas voyez c'est plus pour le
format pour me regarder des films et des
séries tandis que le 3 devis vous en
avez un peu plus qui veut plus est là
pour la productivité donc cette machine
elle va plus être là pour des
commerciaux et des commerciaux
sédentaires parce que bien que ce soit
un ordinateur portable imaginer mettre
ça dans votre sac et le transporter tous
les jours c'est quand même une belle
bête une belle bête de presque 2 kg
1,99 kg alors même si on peut l'emmener
le soir pour continuer à travailler ou
week-end à la maison si on a envie si on
aime travailler nos cadets la maison ça
c est à vous de voir elias et pas
forcément là pendant le plus de
modularité c'est pas forcément la
machine qu'on va emmener tout le temps
facilement qui format 13 pouces
clairement à noter qu'ici à regarder
geoplin venir nous mais là vous avez de
la performance on aime des raisins de
cette série 5000 c'est un 5800 h on a 16
giga de ram et puis ssd nvm e500 12 giga
et le truc qui est assez énorme avec sa
gelée planck est là parce que j'étais en
train de l'utiliser ces blocs de charge
il est juste père hyper hyper hyper
mastoc cdu 135 watts regardez ce truc là
alors il est comme l'ordinateur je
dirais qu'il est quand même un peu
massif mais par contre il vous permettra
de recharger tous très facilement et
très rapidement comme vous avez là à
plat une recharge est bien en usb c'est
si vous voulez venir faire de leurs
recharges rapides notamment pour votre
paie 50 proa vous pouvez le faire très
facilement et sans dommages a pas votre
smartphone donc c'est cool alors après
on a tout ce qu'on attend d'un pc
effectivement des haut parleurs sur le
côté avec regarder je vous fait écouter
très rapidement alors le son est un peu
médium c'est pas là qu'on va voir la
meilleure expérience ça manque un poil
de grave mais ça fonctionne et si vous
voulez regarder parce que plage vous le
monde sait ici la meilleure expérience
vous l'aurez carrément ici en branchant
un petit casque sur une prise jack tant
que je suis là je vous montre les
connectiques voilà vous avez du hdmi ça
c'est plutôt bien j'ai des amis 2.0 pour
bien branché un moniteur externe si vous
le souhaitez deux prises usb c est de
l'autre côté vous avez un plat
ici ces deux prises usb très classique
donc on a quand même ce qu'il faut ce
qui conviendra pour venir brancher des
appareils sans aucun problème et on est
si une caméra qui est planqué ici
directement dans le clavier alors c'est
parce que je préfère avoir ou et a
commencé effectivement vous proposer des
caméras qui sont flanqués en haut de
votre écran avec des gravures laser et
ça coûte un peu plus cher à faire et ils
ont préféré venir à jouer sur le prix en
mai dans sept caméras planquées ici
directement dans le clavier pour vous
proposer un meilleur tarif sur cet
ordinateur si c'est pas une bécane qui
est fait pour le gaming n'est plus pour
la productivité alors une fois de plus
je reverse cet écran parce que vous avez
un taux de rafraîchissement de 60 hertz
qui conviendra parfaitement bien pour
tout ce qui va être séries films
divertissement bureautique pour la
productivité que ce soit professionnel
ou familial on a une luminosité à 310
qu'on est là pour venir bosser dans
votre bureau sans souci un contraste de
1500 pour ans parce qu'ici on est sur du
lcd jc le lit ps on n'a pas contre 1 07
milliard de couleurs un delta e qui est
inférieur à 1 et un ratio écran regarder
bord qui est de 90% ce qui fait que ça
fait quand même vraiment la part belle à
votre écran ici et attention une dalle
brillante donc si vous craignez dalle
brillante c'est peut-être pas pour vous
si vous préférez une dalle mate ce
n'était pas celui à qui vous faudra
mener une dalle brillante qui est très
jolie qui par contre à nouveau dit n'est
pas du tout tactile voilà donc si vous
lâchez du tactile c'est pas ici qu'il
faut aller et bien évidemment certifié
tüv rheinland on va donc venir lutter
contre la lumière bleue contre l'effet
flickr qui d'ailleurs fatigant alors
l'autre truc qui est sympa et si on a
des finition premium elle et ça c'est du
métal en fait que vous allez avoir ici
en ce sens le toucher froid vous avez un
très très grand trackpad qui est
vachement bien et qui vous servira bas
pour venir à bout j'ai travaillé très
facilement ses parts au tour rapide ici
c'est vraiment un côté plus mécanique et
en plus ce trackpad il est vachement
bien pourquoi parce qu'on peut venir
faire du huawei chair très facilement
ils ont augmenté la surface de nfc la
surface de contact pour venir partager
du contenu on vous connaissez un peu
l'histoire fait déjà montre et hop là
vous posez là vous connecter directement
à votre pc et qu'est ce qui va se passer
magie opère up la regarde et je retrouve
l'écran de mon smartphone là j'ai plus
qu'à venir bouger ici savouges
directement dans la mare même manière
avec mon pc si par exemple je veux venir
ouvrir j'en sais rien moi mes paramètres
hop ça ne vous directement les
paramètres dans mon smartphone je peux
venir naviguer très facilement donc ça
c'est vachement bien alors que c'est
pareil un copier/coller glisser-déposer
vous tapez des sms directement depuis
votre bécane donc lire à côté qui est
extrêmement pratique et bien en plus de
ça si vous avez des moniteurs des
médiaux bien pouvait bien faire du
mirroring c'est à dire partager l'écran
de votre ordinateur et l'afficher sur
votre mais dieu vous pouvez également si
vous êtes dans l'écosystème complet avec
votre tablette de huawei venir partager
très facilement côté graphique c'est une
amd radeon ce qui conviendra
parfaitement bien une fois de plus pour
tes productivité pas de game in ici on a
bien évidemment du wifi 6 d'ubuntu seul
point je vous ai montré le nfc avec
huawei cher et windows 11 qui intégrait
directement leur windows os je vous ai
fait une vidéo pour vous présenter les
nouveautés de windows ans quand il a été
présenté est sortie ça marche très très
bien vous êtes toutes vos à bref ils ont
fait un boulot qui est assez intéressant
hop là à vous retrouver hop là on a tous
mutualiser ce côté bref windows os c'est
bien ça marche bien et là ça me plaît en
plus de ça ils vous ont bien petits
boutons et cyril fait office de capteur
d'empreintes digitales pour
déverrouiller extrêmement rapidement si
vous avez un nouveau système de
ventilation de refroidissement avec des
ventilateurs qui vont être plantés on
commence à le deuxième qui peut ici avec
des pales qui vont être plus il donc
plus silencieuse mais toujours très
efficace et surélevée on le voit là sur
le côté pour permettre une bonne
dissipation thermique et on a une
batterie de 84 water ou hawaii nous
annonce 12h30 en lecture full hd alors
vous aurez pas 12h30 avec full hd parce
que l'idée c'est de regarder des films
des séries pendant 12 heures 30 l'idée
c'est de se dire qu'elle est en dessous
de 10 heures vous y êtes sans problème
au niveau de la bureautique entre 9 et
10 heures en fonction de vos usages en
fonction de la luminosité que vous allez
mettre fonction des applications vous
allez faire tourner derrière et comme
vous avez cette recherche très rapide
hop là et bien en 15 minutes vous avez
récupéré 3h30 et vous rechargez de 0 à
100 en 1h45 ah oui une grosse batterie
forcément ça prend du temps ouais pour
la caméra on n'a pas tout le plus dingue
c'est du 720p et on peut regarder ses
poils de nez comme ça tu peux voir si je
me suis bien épilée ou pas après le
bénéfice ici ses côtés confidentialité
sécurité vous êtes sûr que lorsqu'il est
baissée et bien personne peut venir vous
regardez on a deux tarifs sur cette
machine là alors attendez je vous donne
ça vous pouvez la voir en arrière 5 à
partir de 1000 199,99 et en r 7300 49,99
donc ça c'est vraiment l'idée de la
machine qu'on va venir utiliser pour la
bureautique du rôti familial bureautique
professionnelle on a également deux
micros avec une portée de 5000 pour
collaborer facilement enfin bref foyer
c'est un truc qui fonctionne très bien
qui est bien mais qui y est quand même
une très très grosse bécane donc si on
veut un pc et qu'on veut un pc qui est
un peu moins gros et bien on a un truc
est vraiment très très différents et
c'est là où arrive le macbook alors le
met debout que je trouve quand même
vachement bien pourquoi parce qu'une
fois de plus on est dans l'idée de la
machine qu'on va venir emmener avec soi
très facilement et là dessus une fois de
plus je suis sur un pc voyez quand même
les deux salles deux ambiances coin là
honnêtement ça ça fait c'est quand même
quand j'ai l'autre à côté sympa calme
vachement plus lourd 1 kg 99 puis à
combler sur le macbook est beaucoup plus
léger 709 car alors il ya effectivement
la petite cover qui est un peu un peu
plus et le stylet mais c'est assez
négligent et donc on est quand même à
moins d'un kilo ça c'est vachement bien
quand je les ai vus je me suis dit si
une tablette ce truc est en fait sa
trompe son monde alors ça dépend ce
qu'on veut en faire attention parce
qu'on n'a pas ici un très très grand
écran car déjà je vous dis que le
système de votre cover vous prenez vous
l'enlever ça vient se poser là voyez
vous à des petits picots juste en bas la
connectique est elle est là vous le
prenez vous l'insérer vous le mettez
bien en face et ensuite votre cover là
elle va se plier à l'arrière ou et ça
vous sert le petit cheval et donc après
vous lui mettez l'inclinaison que vous
voulez si vous voulez être plus ou moins
inclinés ou pas on va lui mettre une
matinée zon un petit peu comme ça pour
les besoins de la vidéo pour vous
puissiez voir le clavier avec un vrai
retour de touche à ça c'est aussi
vachement intéressant parce qu'on
pourrait se dire comme ça ressemble à
une tablette alors ce n'est vraiment pas
une on n'aurait pas un bon retour de
touché pour autant je sûr que là dessus
on a vraiment un bon retour de touche
donc ça ça marche bien ou vrai clavier
très très bon retour de tout je trouve
que le trackpad est aussi assez grand
donc ça ça fonctionne également c'est
vraiment l'idée de l'hybride un pc
hybride deux ans non je le prends je
peux venir le détacher ça me serve
tablette même si c'est pas une tablette
c'est format tablette je peux venir
bosser en mode ordinateur à la maison
attention si si on a une balle qui est
un peu plus petites ont descendu 12,6
pouces et ben ouais c'est pas
extrêmement grand par contre ici on les
tactiles on peut venir le faire
directement alors empreintes digitales
j'ai un capteur ici rd je pose mon doigt
ça des verrous ça c'est cool on n'est
pas sur une dalle mate cadets vous
pouvez me voir là haut up la coucou
coucou je suis là on est dans la
brillante on est sur une dalle de casser
ici un écran oled est pas du lcd donc
des contraste infini vous savez combien
pixels noirs saint pie x à l'état se
permet d'éviter de consommer et
d'économiser sa batterie 2560 par 1600
pixels déborde 5,6 mm à l'aller on va la
mettre à plat c'est quand même
extrêmement fin là par contre on est de
webcams qui est planqué juste ici ça
c'est assez pratique on a également une
certification tuv rheinland qui va venir
lutter contre la lumière bleue et contre
l'effet flickr pour me reposer vos yeux
donc ça c'est cool et on va jusqu'à 610
c'est la lumineux ite maximale c'est ce
que je vous ai mis et ont fait regarder
c'est pas très grand ça fait cette
conversation chiffres-là 7 99 mm
d'épaisseur vraiment l'idée d'une
tablette puis vous avez un touché qui
est vachement doula au niveau de ce
clavier alors c'est toujours un peu
marrant parce que une fois de plus dans
la même idée de huawei cher quand vous
montez sur le macbook 16 comme on a ici
sur un pc et non pas une tablette eh
bien j'ai exactement de la même manière
au plat huawei cher je prends je pose
mon smartphone il se connecte et c'est
vraiment ça qui est vachement
intéressant dans cette notion
d'écosystème si vous avez un smartphone
de huawei je vais retrouver mon
smartphone qui peut venir naviguer de la
même manière tactile alors une brise un
peu l'écran pour venir économiser la
batterie mais sinon c'est exactement la
même chose donc de la même manière des
copier coller des glisser-déposer du
texte je tape j'envoie des sms pour
répondre au téléphone directement à
partir de mon ordi que c'est ans d'ordis
pas une tablette de mon macbook eux pour
être très précis et j'ai un angle
d'ouverture et 6 et entre 110 et 160
degrés donc veuillez hop là ça c'est le
début et ensuite je peux aller juste
heures donc ça c'est vrai que c'est
aussi extrêmement pratique pour venir
bosser si vous vous dites maintien je
veux vraiment quelque chose je suis pas
là même auteur donc là je le mets
vraiment cet angle-là a contrario comme
là pour bien vous le montrez je peux me
recoucher davantage donc on peut
vraiment faire ce qu'on veut dans sa
pratique aussi le clavier pèse 460
grammes et puis bien évidemment et vous
le voyez depuis tout à l'heure je les
mets au dessus même si j'ai pas encore
utilisé vous avez un stylet et ben ouais
le elle pencil de deuxième génération
que je peux venir utiliser avec alors
l'idée c'est en fonction des besoins de
chacun on va pas tous venir utiliser un
stylet mais si vous le souhaitez vous le
pouvez nous cueille un vrai côté de
différencier du macbook 16 c'est à dire
que le macbook 16 c'est votre pad
l'écran n'est pas tactile donc on est
dans l'idée d'une configuration pc un
peu plus standard alors on a quelque
chose d'un peu plus page dire
fantaisiste mais un peu plus transverses
on peut faire plus de choses on peut
venir dessiner griffonné prendre des
notes travailler directement avec son
mpenza moi je suis pas un gros
utilisateur de stylet mais je sais qu'il
ya beaucoup qu'ils le sont donc c'est
intéressant de pouvoir voir ça on peut
venir effectivement mais on a des tâches
en appuyant deux fois sur le dessus on
peut venir faire des choses à regarder
au pelage appui dessiner une forme pour
prendre une capture d'écran hop là je
dessine une forme ça me fait une capture
d'écran je fais juste tac tac hop là je
peux bien faire des captures d'écran je
peux bien faire pas mal de choses donc
et pas mal de gestes qu'on peut venir
appliqué à différentes applications saas
est aussi extrêmement intéressant donc
on voit qu'en fonction de ses usagers de
ces besoins ici pour pourra faire un peu
plus de choses on peut également
utiliser plus facilement pour le mettre
dans un sac pour partir ce soit à titre
personnel ou à titre professionnel s'est
tous regardés en termes de connectique
alors y'a pas grand chose parce qu'on
est effectivement sur un pc mais format
tablette mais vous allez voir une prise
jack ici pour optimiser l'expérience
audio vous avez effectivement votre
bouton qui font office de capteur
d'empreintes digitales aux boutons de
volume qui se situe juste là et vous
avez une prise usb c'est en bas qui vous
permettra notamment de viendra charger
et on est ici sur deûle intel core 2 11e
génération on a un i3 ou i5 sur le i 3
on aura moins de performances que sur le
hic c'est que ça paraît très logique
donc le i3 c'est vraiment pour de la
petite productivité à familiale vous
vous dites ok voire professionnel vous
avez un tableur traite mon texte et
compagnie ok mais si vous voulez aller
un peu plus loin que les applications un
poil plus gourmandes pas penser à des
photos chocs de lightroom soca on peut
bien effectivement faire de la retouche
photo avec notamment son style et ça
c'est pratique parce que vous vous
déplacez ou jeux par exemple c'est pas
vrai on fait une photo avec un pote p50
pro vous la partagez directement avec
awa cheikh et vous venez l'éditer là et
ensuite vous l'aviez sur les réseaux
donc un truc qui est aussi très sympa
pour les créateurs qui comme moi sont
beaucoup en mobilité avec moïse 3g une
config en 8 gigas de ram j'ai un ssd nvm
de 128 go de stockage et avec -8 5 g 16
giga de ram et 512 giga de stockage et
après vous avez des bundles des package
pour bien acheter soit tout seul si vous
le souhaitez ou alors carrément ici avec
votre clavier ce qui me paraîtra plus
logique et même ce qui peut être
intéressant si vous voulez l'utiliser si
ça vous intéresse pourquoi pas de
prendre à une peine si la voir on a du
bluetooth cinq points on a du wifi si ce
qui me paraît logique aujourd'hui il ya
noté sur les versions i3 vous n'avez pas
la possibilité d'avoir la collaboration
multi écrans donc ça il faut le savoir
uniquement à partir de la version i5 et
autres différences également entre les
deux versions sur la version i 3 vous
avez un windows en mode s lire un poil
plus [ __ ] avec uniquement les
applications disponibles sur le store de
microsoft tandis que si vous êtes sur un
i5 vous avez un windows rose débridée
classique standard alors après on peut
très bien très honnêtement de vous à moi
sur un étroit faire péter le mode s mais
on peut pas y revenir après donc bon ça
sert à rien d'aller prendre des
applications gourmandes que vous allez
trouver ailleurs parce que votre machine
ne le supportera pas donc il faut
vraiment savoir sur quoi on va en fait
qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire quels sont
les usages bureautiques pour utilité
légère i3 on a besoin de plus de
performances i5 tout de suite et puis
vous avez également un système de
refroidissement parce que c'est un
ordinateur et non pas une tablette avec
une chambre à vapeur ultra-minces
refroidi par air alors vous passe très
très rapidement côté technique mais
c'est avec la rade et ça fait pas du
tout bruit j'entends absolument rien
donc on est quelque chose de vraiment
très très silencieux et puis si vous
regardez pas ce qu'on vous dirais ok
monsieur voter des minions tu me parles
de ventilateurs et tout mais très
clairement que je vois ça ressemble à
une tablette il n'ya pas d'extraction
d'herbe ainsi en fait l extraction d'air
mais aller extrêmement discrète regarde
tout l'extraction d'air se fait par le
dessus pour une très très bonne
dissipation thermique donc hop lors fait
le point donc ça ça marche alors on le
sent effectivement lorsqu'on va
l'utiliser de façon un petit peu
hardcore vous allez sentir que l'air
passe par là si vous posez votre mandat
mais sinon vous sentez pas une super
expérience on a ici je les laisse hélas
une charge rapide 65 watts qu'on peut
venir également utilisé avec votre paie
50 pro si vous le souhaitez une batterie
de 42 water en 30 minutes de charge vous
avez 54% de batteries récupérer et la
charge complète ces 90 minutes on a
quatre haut parleurs on a quatre micros
l'idée c'est d'avoir une super
expérience immersive lorsqu'on veut
venir écouter de la musique lorsqu'on
veut dire regarder des vidéos et du
contenu de la même manière à ce qu'on a
besoin de faire une conférence on peut
le faire extrêmement facilement parce
que vous avez une webcam qui est planqué
juste là et ça je voulais dit là pour le
coup on est en full hd donc voyez il ya
un truc qui est plutôt rigolo et comme
on est dans l'esprit look and feel
tablettes ils ont fait un truc assez
marrant c'est à dire qu'ils vous ont
même intégré une caméra au dos on se
dira alors un coup de jean sérien tu ne
sais pas une tablette mais ça ressemble
à une tablette et c'est là où c'est
marrant d'avoir un vrai hybride comme ça
parce que vous voyez pas plus là alors
attendez j'ai pas grand chose à lui de
films et là je peux venir imposer par
exemple - une panne si loyer alors je
sais pas si je vais le prendre pour
aller faire des photos en extérieur mais
en tout cas si j'ai besoin et si je
souhaite l'utiliser ma caméra arrière je
peux donc je peux souhaiter de la même
manière très facilement entre la caméra
avant et la caméra donc ça c'est cool
tout en sachant qu'à la manche et de la
mer de 8 mégapixels qui planquaient la
paix d'une 13 mégapixels qui est planqué
jusqu'au dos ici voyez avec un petit
flash bon et après je vous passe très
rapidement le m pencil c'est de la
deuxième génération j 4096 au point de
pression ça c'est un très très grand
standard une latence de 2 millisecondes
et une autonomie de dix heures donc si
vous êtes vous clients dans
l'utilisation d'un stylet regardez là le
n va t'il de deuxième génération il a
rien à envier aux autres je voulais
montrer tout à l'heure vous avez de la
charge induction vous le prenez vous le
posez juste là et là il vient se
recharger et ça c'est bien et vous avez
des offres de précommande du 8 au 21
mars pour l'achat d'un macbook 16h07 16
512 au prix de mille 349,99 vous avez un
mec view j'étais 27 pouces et à wau
médocs de offert vous avez un mac book
16 et recettes 16 plus 512 avec 200
euros de réduction plus une waro et
bluetooth mouse 2 offerte pour 1149
euros 99 ou alors vous avez carrément un
netbook 16h05 16 plus 512 igga avec 200
euros de réduction et une huawei
bluetooth mouse 2 offerts pour 999 99 et
pour les macbook e en pré commande à
partir du 1er avril vous avez votre voix
ou et macbook le x5 cesse plus 512 à
1299 99 clavier inclus avec le m pencil
offerts sur le site de huawei et vous
avez également la config mais boukehil
3,8 plus 256 à 649 99 sans clavier ici
avec le m pencil offerts sur le site de
huawei ici le clavier sera vendu
séparément au tarif de 159 euros 99 tout
en sachant qu'ici vous avez une seule
couleur c'est le nebula gré vous l'aurez
dans ce gris la très simple très mignon
on voyait on est vraiment dans l'idée
d'avoir deux salles deux ambiances
fruits mais un socle commun c'est quoi
c'est l'idée de l'écosystème c'est
l'idée du partage si vous avez un acte
fou à la maison un écran de huawei sauf
sur la config i3 et je tiens vraiment à
le préciser une fois de plus et bien
vous allez pouvoir venir collaborer
facilement partager afficher autant je
pars avec ça en mobilité avec -5 su à la
maison je le prends j'ai un moniteur ça
ne l'affichent en grand et ça c'est
vachement cool parce que j'ai un
meilleur confort pour les yeux mais pour
autant j'ai un clavier qui hélas est un
vrai clavier son cash peut travailler
son rougir son problème donc pour tout
ce qu'ils veulent je dirais créativité
prise de notes mobilité pour la
productivité familiale professionnelle
et ceux qui veulent se balader avoir
toujours léger dans la poche mais avec
une performance correcte on est sur un
an ils 5 2 11e génération est bien avec
le met debout que vous avez vraiment
tout est fait pour vous qui est sur
mesure donc ça c'est intéressant a
contrario si vous préférez l'ordinateur
un peu plus grand avec un côté un peu
plus conventionnel
le mail look 16 très grand écran très
bonne qualité vous avez finition en
premium une très belle machine vous
voyez c'est ça qui est intéressant avec
ce que vient aujourd'hui nous propose et
huawei si c'est une solution complète
pour tout le monde c'est dire le macbook
air n'est pas forcément fait pour vous
mais le macbook 16 non plus donc à
savoir quel est votre idée qu'est ce que
vous aimez caso vos goûts et quels sont
vos besoins est-ce que premièrement vous
avez besoin d'un stylet ce que
deuxièmement vous êtes beaucoup à
mobilité vous avez besoin dans les
machines très facilement partout avec
vous et est-ce qu'avec un écran de un
peu plus de 12 pouces ça pourrait vous
convenir ou est-ce que vous préférez a
contrario un écran 16 pouces pour un peu
plus de confort de visionnage heures
dites moi ça en bas en commentaire et
n'oubliez pas tout ce qui est
intéressant dans l'écosystème huawei
c'est effectivement la notion de partage
la notion de communication tous les
appareils devenir comique et très
facilement entre eux et ça ça me plaît
ça je trouve ça intéressant donc voilà
il pas ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire nous retrouve vite très vite
pour continuer à parler texte vous
présenter des produits des solutions
intéressantes à savoir lesquels peuvent
vous convient parce que je suis là pour
vous aider avant toute chose voilà vous
embrasse vous aime pour les soins de
vous
[Musique]